[موسيقى]
منذ اكثر من مئه وعشرين عاما تتوارث اسره
الحرف السعوديه احمد الفوزان صناعه
الابواب والنوافذ التراثيه ونقشها بزخارف
النجديه باشكال الهندسيه تعكس الهويه
العمرانيه الفريده في منطقه نجد
اهتمامهم قديما بالابواب
برده الجبصيات وكذا لكن الابواب برضه لها
لها نقوش خاصه لناديه يعني
الفوزان يصنعوا الابواب التراثيه والنوافذ
التي تعرف محليا باسم المصاريف من جدوعي
اشجار الاثل البلدي التي تمتاز بسماكتها
ومقاومتها للعوامل المناخيه للمكان حيث
يستغرق العمل في صناعه باب بطول ثلاثه
امتار اسبوعا والله الخشب الاثل هو
الاساسي اللي نستخدمه ونبع النخل
هذه هي ال- ال- المواد اللي نستخدمها من
الطبيعه
[موسيقى]
حتى يحافظ على هذه الحرفه من الاندثار
ويستمر ارث عائلته اسس احمد الفوزان من
جره يدرب فيها ابناءه الذين تعلموا اسرار
الحرفه على يديه
الحمد لله علمنا عبد الله وعبد الرحمن وان
شاء الله ان امي بيمسكونا باذن الله
ونوافذ التي صنعها ويشارك بها في
المهرجانات والمعارض الدوليه لتعرف بهذه
الحرفه التقليديه وفنون النقش والزخارف
النجديه التي تعكس الثقافه السعوديه كان
اخرها معرض ارتجانو في ايطاليا
غدا الفهد العربيه الرياض